coming up on the wildlife of Dr Oli what
I am concerned about is a mass in that
nasal cavity sometimes vet work is
detective work it's a number you saw how
snotty and how like oh I picked her nose
before we got started Bingo you finally
get the answer come on buddy sometimes
it's like teaching yeah if it weren't
for you I wouldn't be standing here
doing this right now so I thank you you
got it and sometimes it's like an action
movie
we're going to make Mr Stubbs bigger
stronger faster
this is fascinating
[Music]
White Mountain is hopping today sure I
will have to go back in with and ask the
text because my doctor has about five
surgeries today
okay we're on our way she can go back up
to Mom I got a couple prescriptions to
fill
gonna be okay Mr Cuddles when a prized
pet bunny comes in to see the dock
get dip fixed with an uncomfortable
issue affecting his undercarriage it's
gonna be okay we are here with our grand
champion Mr Cuddles who is a Holland Lop
rabbit he's had so many first places and
Bunny shows he has a big broad head and
just certain details that make him a
good show funny
so what's going on with him today
um we think he's a UTI he's been
urinating a lot for her okay and is it
getting worse or is it about this
afternoon oh yeah he continues to lose
hair
his legs are almost bare now yeah and so
every morning my mom or I clean his
bottom and then blow dry it dry
yeah you guys are definitely taking good
care of them considering what's going on
keeping them nice and clean I know it's
okay the judges would not like to see
him losing fur all across his legs and I
felt really sad when I saw that because
I didn't know if he was gonna be okay
I know it's scary nobody likes coming to
the doctor Mr cuddle's career as a show
bunny may be cut short by this problem
but his lack of signature fluff could
also signal something much more serious
he's okay he's at the best place he
could be right now huh yeah it's all
right you're okay hopefully Dr Ali can
figure out what's going on with him
hello hi Dr Olney how are you doing this
morning we are feeling hopeful thank you
Jill tells me that Mr Cuddles has urine
scalding on his hind limbs this is
usually from prolonged contact with his
urine like sitting in it he doesn't
actually try to assume the position he
simply just pees but I believe there's a
much bigger issue going on in his body I
want to just take a good look at the
anatomy down there for starters we want
to run a urinalysis on him things that
are going through my mind he has some
kind of a problem with his his ability
to urinate urinary bladder all the way
through the urethra or he has a back
injury which rabbits can be prone to so
perhaps a spinal X-ray as well so that
would be great we'll try to get the
answers today and then I'll go over
everything with you when you come to
pick him up okay thank you
Mr Cuddles
[Music]
it's a lot you got it
good boy
I have got you scheduled and we will see
you at 11 30. the clinic is jumping this
morning
we are done
when doc oli's former Apprentice arrives
with two Feathered Friends I was just
coming in to have Dr Early take a look
at my Hawks we got uh dagger and then I
brought his girlfriend Freya she's a
she's squawking but she's a female
Harris Hawk and then this is a male
Harris Hawk it is hard to pick favorite
she love them all but I have a special
bond with this guy you know the sport of
falconry it's ancient instead of hunting
with a gun or a bow and arrow you can
hunt with a bird and you catch small
stuff rabbits Ducks Quail it is always
good with the animal like this just for
Dr Oli to take a look he's a bat who
knows about Raptors which is rare hey
dog how's it going good seeing you
thought I'd bring the Hawks in for their
yearly checkup let me hear you
I always love seeing well man Birds I
was in my early teens when I developed a
Fascination for Raptors and then when I
found out you can actually train them
and fly with them I thought nothing's
better than taking your Hawk for a walk
so I got into it and now I'm a master
Falconer how old were you when you were
my Apprentice I was 15 15 when I first
called you he helped me get my license
he taught me how to do it I mean he's
just the most helpful guy I wouldn't be
able to do it without you so I
appreciate it well shoot so are these
captive Rays or did you trap them both
of them are Captain Brad He's three
she's six months Harris's Hawks are
really cool Birds they're known as The
Wolves of the sky because they're the
only Raptor that hunts in social groups
like a pack you don't have any
fluctuations in weights I mean they're
staying pretty steady yeah I mean I'm
pretty much flying her at 700 grams this
guy I'm flying at about 620. I got to
keep him that weight because I'm doing
the pigeon thing for business tell me
more about that are we doing all natural
pest control thing now any place that's
got a pigeon problem I just bring the
Hawks by we fly them she's catching
about five pigeons a day he'll catch up
to ten when he catches a pigeon I'll
just give him a little piece of food and
he'll get off it and then he'll go catch
another one go catch another one go
catch another one yeah I imagine once
you get the pigeons aware of the fact
that there's a couple of Harris Hawks in
the area they probably just vacate on
their own don't they yep we've had great
success we have apartment complexes huge
HOAs parking garages we're getting more
work than we can handle right now I
remember when Nick came to me and he was
you know it's wide-eyed wet behind the
ears teenager just all things Raptor and
very excited about wanting to become an
apprentice and I took him on and you
know he's become a professional Falconer
kind of a nice transition to see some of
my students do so well let's have a look
at your birds
grabbing once you can't see me yeah when
captive Raptors are nervous we put a
hood on them and that eliminates all
visual stimulus it basically keeps them
calm
what about you
sweetheart oh he's a great bird I've
never had a problem with him I clipped
his Beak he hasn't sharpened it yet no
you bite that for me
it's not grossly overgrown he's a pretty
calm guy I mean if you can get an emery
board on there the thing with an emery
board to sharpen that up is as many
strokes as you do on that side make sure
you do the same one and that will keep
that beak even it'll keep wearing it
down and it will shrink it back up okay
well uh Nick they look great they feel
great as long as their weights are
holding I'm going to give them straight
A's on their report card today yeah I
think the next thing to do is go watch
them fly yeah let's do it
boy
you want to try for all the time's sake
sure oh God
come on buddy
get everybody Chase everything
[Music]
tell you what go go over there next to
that fence I want to see them fly a
little longer distance and call him okay
fine
go over
good boy
come on buddy
boy
good boy
yeah that's yeah he's flying really
strong Nick
I've had probably five or six
apprentices over the years it's a sport
that hasn't changed for centuries it's
almost like martial arts I was a Sensei
to those guys and now they're my black
belt buddies he's a good boy sure dagger
if it weren't for you I wouldn't be
standing here doing this right now so I
thank you thank you for all you did
[Music]
that's pretty good dad
I would probably recommend that this dog
have any collar because these are the
ones that they want to get to I'll be
right with you okay
[Music]
okay
there he is
all right sweetheart it's time to solve
the mystery of what's ailing Mr Cuddles
a little gas anesthetic will help him
relax enough so doc can start to look
for Clues easy babe just a little not
quite not quite but he's getting there
this bunny is obviously suffering from
something otherwise he wouldn't be
sitting in his own urine and you have to
be methodical to get to the bottom of it
the way I was taught you start with a
physical exam and you try to find it a
problem sometimes the physical exam will
actually give you the answer
it's not seeing a lot of abnormal about
his General Anatomy town here but if not
then you start going through the
Diagnostics to rule in or rule out the
suspected diagnosis
let me get some urine so we can run a
urinalysis later
pretty normal urine to me
they have really turbid thick urine like
that basically you narrow it down all
right let's do an x-ray go do the voodoo
that you do so well all right
just like the entire spine doctor always
yeah let's just do a full body lateral
okay then let's hand recover him because
he's going to wake up pretty quickly
[Music]
Bingo you finally get the answer
yeah that lumbosacral joint doesn't look
so hot this is where they're going to
injure their back if they kick and
they're not supported and you can see on
the top of that joint space how much
bony proliferation there is and it's
almost closed down completely on the top
part of that joint I think that's our
problem this approach to diagnosing a
problem has never failed me that is what
to me being a diligent responsible and
effective veterinarian is all about
speak you up
let's go see Mr Cuddles
all right we got an answer today oh my
gosh didn't find anything anatomically
wrong with him at all urine was
completely normal great okay but on
x-rays we have some changes
back here I want to show you just the
spinal Anatomy so this is a vertebrae
that's a disk space vertebrae disk space
okay and then up here in the lumbosacral
joint it's completely occluded near the
top and if you look up here there's some
bone being laid down that's what happens
when the body's trying to stabilize an
unstable situation okay it's spinal
arthritis oh wow and that comes with age
I'm wondering if you didn't injure
himself one of the things that rabbits
are prone to is when they're scared and
they try to take off and run they can
kick their hind legs hard enough that
they can actually damage this
lymphosacral joint oh wow we always kind
of cuddle their butts as we tell people
to do so if he kicks he's kicking
against something you know somebody
wasn't supporting him when he was being
restrained and he could have injured
that joint we'll never know right I
think he hurts and he just doesn't want
to move to urinate yeah and so that's
why he's just sitting in his litter box
exactly okay so I gave him an injection
of a Time released anti-inflammatory
this injection should last him at least
a month oh great so I'm going to try to
take the pain away take the inflammation
away see if we can make him a little bit
more mobile if he's active then he has
choices and he's not just urinating on
himself right hopefully we'll get the
urine scald salt and her growing back on
his legs yes Mr Cuddles he's a well
decorated 4-H bunny he should have a
very long life so I'm expecting really
great results
oh he's hungry
hungry Dr Oley actually helped my buddy
that's some more
he's brought us a lot of joy and
hopefully a beginning of a comfortable
retirement for Mr Cuddles we'll keep in
touch bye
some of dakoli's patients may not be the
cuddliest but they still deserve the
best care today's house call is it a
herpetological sanctuary that rescues
and rehabs reptiles wow wow that is
about the biggest Asian water monitor
I've ever seen Rowdy the monitored
lizard is getting up there in years but
lately he's not living up to his full
Rowdy potential is he having any kind of
mobility issues or yeah he's moving much
slower
um and you'll see when we get to working
with him a little bit his uh his front
arms especially seem really stiff now
he's getting old he's about 26. how old
is old for a monitor does he still have
a lot of 26 26.
normally monitors live about 15 16 years
the best and he's 26 and I think that is
a testament to the Fine care that Daniel
and staff has given him he's still
kicking I just don't want to see the day
when he's not but yeah I know that
Daniel and the team are really attached
to Rowdy and I fear that they think the
end is near
we'd start talking about him not eating
with us that's hard
he's getting old he's about 26. and he's
still kicking I just don't want to see
the day when he's not but yeah
we'd start talking about him not being
with us it's hard I'm very close to him
it's like you know a sibling or a child
you know something happens to him that's
it's it hurts he's just been with us so
long and I've done so much with him he's
definitely got to be my number one he's
very special to me
I'm probably going to take some x-rays
after I examine him so I'll go grab the
X-ray machine if you want to bring him
I'll meet you over in the in the clinic
okay we'll do that all right sounds
great monitor lizards are a very unique
lizard that's native to Africa Asia and
Australia what's unique about the
monitor lizard is it has a snake-like
tongue it's always testing its
environment that tongue is constantly
giving Rowdy information on what's
around him who's around him and whether
or not he needs to be concerned about
anything so Daniel I noticed when he was
in his habitat he's resting his head on
the branch and but he was standing on
these front limbs do you suppose that
was a mechanism for him to take some
weight off the front end a little bit
possibly when they're basking when
they're wanting to soak up that UV light
they're generally standing the hind
limbs are down on the ground and the
front limbs are up and that exposes as
much of their body to sunlight as
possible what I noticed though he had
his head resting on that log that was my
first clue that he's trying to you use
his head to take some of the weight off
his elbows hey buddy
eyes look pretty clear you can say ah
for me that's a good man
Quail slits look good everything is good
in there that's a good breath nice and
clear heart sounds perfect
Daniel I gotta tell you I can't believe
how Tammy is I mean I've worked on
lizards and zoos and we have to
anesthetize them to get an exactly like
this then he used to move around and be
much more mobile than he is now but
we've noticed his arms appear to be
stiff he kind of moves really yeah
rickety like an old man actually I'm
just what I'm seeing is just a decreased
range of motion it feels like in this
elbow it does
doesn't act like he likes that very much
so that might be the source of his
mobility issues just get those X-rays
and see if we can address his mobility
issues okay
okay you see that ready light click it
all the way down
okay good perfect
dang we got a picture
okay see this elbow right here there's
some demineralization you see this is
fairly normal bone up here I blow that
up we get down to the lower part of the
humerus see how it looks kind of moth
eaten you see all these these calcium
deposits out here outside yeah on the
outside down at the elbow joint that is
indicative of arthritis and that's why
he's not being mobile anymore range of
motion was definitely decreased in those
elbows and I watched him as he was
trying to move with those elbows even on
the Slick table that he just wasn't
bending his limbs correctly 26 year old
elbows you know yeah I think we can help
that what I would do is we're going to
put him on a non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory or the discomfort and
just monitor his mobility and see how he
does with that well we get another 26
years I'll be happy I bet you would he
may not ever be that spry again but he
should be more spry than he is now once
we start therapy I don't think he'll
ever be the Rowdy he used to be think
old man you know if Rowdy even shows a
little inkling of what his old Rowdy
self was I'd be very happy to know that
all right Jill I guess we can pack some
stuff up here and head up to Mr stubs
all right sounds good all right
oli's next patient also has a Mobility
Challenge
and this is the man of the hour here Mr
Stubbs huh
but this one is for a very different
reason another Gator bit his tail off
when he was a baby an alligator with no
tail poses some problems for him and we
want to see with a veterinary's opinion
can we design that perfect tail that
makes him feel as comfortable as
possible than he and he can act and
behave and be as normal as he can as an
alligator Mr Stubbs had a prosthetic
tale that helped but he's outgrown it
now doco lead a team including an
anatomy professor and a prosthetist are
going to design him a high-tech upgrade
we've tried a couple of different ways
of getting a good secure fit around this
stump and actually that's the problem
where we are right now with the new tail
we have to develop as he's grown so much
he's lost a little bit of the Contour on
this stump and so now we're having a
hard time keeping a tail on around that
big bulge there and it can just slip
right off if he turns the wrong
direction okay just do a quick physical
exam on him and just make sure he's in
good shape all the way around oh
[Music]
10 years old Mr stubs should be around
six feet long but without his tail he's
just about three feet
nice big breasts Mr Stubbs please
alligators tails are very very important
to them it represents literally half
their body length about 30 percent of
their total weight and that tail serves
as a fulcrum for the center of gravity
without his tail he can't walk properly
and he certainly can't swim properly so
on the land or on the water Mr Stubbs
has got some issues is there any way I
could see him walk we can always try he
does not a big Walker these days but
we'll give it our best shot
thank you
can tell right away that Mr Stubbs
balance is off by the way he walks when
you think about someone walking on ice
or a wet floor they're taking very small
steps very slow steps and they're even
maybe putting their arms out for balance
as they're walking you can see him doing
all the same things and he's playing his
back legs out wide and then you see to
keep him falling over the deviation of
that lumbar spine yeah yeah she's
normally in a straight line even when
they're walking
yeah he is really uh
not alligator-esque right now
[Music]
yeah he is really uh
not alligator-esque right now
Consulting with a team of experts on an
unusual case
dubs the alligator is struggling
one of our big concerns is that he's
going to develop some sort of arthritis
or musculoskeletal syndrome absolutely
he's loading all his his joints
incorrectly and that cartilage is going
to change and that's going to lead to
arthritis in the long run are there
arthritis medicine for alligators we can
treat arthritis and reptiles the thing
about arthritis is it doesn't get better
it only gets worse much better to
prevent it than to treat it the best
solution for Mr Stubbs is to make his
body mechanics more natural and I think
a new and improved prosthetic tale is
going to help him avoid a very painful
future
where he needs the weight is at the base
of that prosthetic there's a way to
design it where we could have the bulk
of the weight right at the stump and
then have a lighter tail in the end that
he can still use but he doesn't need
that weight out at the tip he needs it
right over his stump luckily for Mr
Stubbs prosthetic technology is
improving every day and that can help
solve this dilemma of a really
well-loved alligator with no tail we're
going to bring him into the laboratory
where we can measure how he moves we've
got a really Advanced Camera system that
can capture the movement in Mr Stubbs in
our room we're going to assess his
walking without the tail and then when
the tail is complete we'll do it again
and see how that tail actually changes
his ability to walk Mr Stubbs gets a
field trip to Mark's lab so we can get
all the information gathered to give him
a brand new tail just like mother nature
intended so we're going to use these
motion capture markers here and all of
those cameras around the room are
shooting infrared light that's going to
bounce off these and they see this so
when we take these markers and we put
them on Mr Stubbs in the right place the
computer sees all those markers it knows
where they are in three dimensions so
that we can see every part of him
movement as he walks back and forth
across the lap nice show me where to put
them okay
Mr Stubbs is like an action hero in a
CGI movie right now
in this lab we are able to measure in
great detail the movement of the human
body or in this case the body of an
alligator so we'll put these reflective
balls all over Mr Subs body and we'll
get a baseline for how he's walking okay
I think he's ready all right let's see
this this is fascinating
and now you can see when he's moving the
computer's seen it in real time oh yeah
I see that every sensor oh that's cool
he's just swinging it I mean he just has
to throw those hind legs to be able to
walk it he is almost bending in half
just to keep himself from tipping over
your eyes can tell you everything the
computer can tell you everything plus
some this detailed information tells the
prosthetic team everything they need to
know to design the perfect new tail for
Mr Stubbs a 3D printer prints a mold
that they will use to make the
prosthetic
he's like the Six Million Dollar
alligator we're gonna make Mr Stubbs
bigger stronger faster just like The
Bionic Man
good job Mr Stubbs
[Music]
staple gun's already on your tray all
right it's a busy day in the OR local
skin staples and we're done when a
beloved German Shepherd who just can't
shake a runny nose hey manding arrives
for a closer look
hey good girl I brought in my
nine-year-old German Shepherd Mandy and
she's been having recurrent nasal
infections I'm feeling sleepy she
sneezes and there is
um some green discharge and some crust
like dog boogers but I kind of knew was
there was something infectious going on
come on girlfriend
did you check her in this morning I did
did she say it's it's been bloody or has
it just been mucus just the mucus so I
saw Mandy about six months ago for this
unilateral or one-sided snotty nose very
simply we started her on antibiotics the
discharge went away but it came back so
now Doc Oli wants to scope Mandy's nose
to find out if there's something more
serious causing her sniffles you're okay
I'm gonna try to do this just under
sedation rather than general anesthesia
all right Mandy hopefully you'll
cooperate with us today what I am really
concerned about is a mass in that nasal
cavity some kind of tumor or polyp
because it's very difficult to operate
in in that narrow space in a dog
see if I can see anything unusual I know
it's uncomfortable pain in there she's a
very sweet German shepherd very
protective of me in her prime she and I
would hike the woods of Germany
literally like five miles up mountains
and now she's kind of slowed down so now
we just hike the paths around here she's
just a wonderful dog my only worry is
what he's going to find yeah you're
right you're right
I brought in my nine-year-old German
Shepherd Mandy and she's been having
recurrent nasal infections see if I can
see anything unusually we really love Dr
Oley we really trust him my only worry
is what he's going to find
well you can see it
it's just not that's for sure but I can
see it in there looks pretty normal
you did good girlfriend sometimes you
have to treat these cases like a
detective systematically looking for
Clues and eliminating causes okay we'll
go with a scope next I can't see
anything really concerning looking in
the front side of her nasal cavity so I
want to be back behind the soft palate
looking back towards the front of her
nose to examine that portion of the
nasal cavity hold the scope okay that's
good
I'm not seeing anything nothing and I
got a good look back there too so here
we'll get this out of your mouth all
right Mindy I want to do a dental Probe
on her okay an abscessed tooth can also
cause a runny nose so I definitely want
to rule that out nothing on that side
it's a tooth this is usually offending
to going all the way around on a dental
probe I'm not seeing anything
good girl there's one more way for me to
get a look into Mandy's head if there's
a tumor it should show up on an X-ray
thank you all right do x-ray I want it
perfectly symmetrical skull X-ray on her
shooting
Dr Jolly x-ray up
just trying to find the source of this
discharge is the goal here when I look
at the trabecular bone it looks like
this fine Lacy bone right here that's
all pretty normal on both sides the good
news is the X-ray doesn't show any
evidence of a tumor or any other problem
that I can see readily in Mandy's head I
had a dachshund one time that
have the same thing and couldn't figure
out can figure it out
and then one day the Dachshund had the
sneezing fit and blew out a piece of
foam that like was chewing on a toy or
something finally fixed itself I think
she's got a foreign body up that nose
and it's just going to have to work
itself out the business end of Mandy and
every dog is its nose I mean that's its
primary sense that it uses to navigate
through this world
and it's not uncommon for them to sniff
something up there and get it stuck good
nap Sandy
inside
okay go ahead and head on down
if I got kind of a crazy practice in
that I'm in and out of town quite a bit
dock only small patients come in the
front door of the clinic but the big
boys wait out back
he's 16 Hands
Henry the horse has a persistent problem
with his nose and mouth so he's back for
a follow-up with Dr Oley
Henry periodically has some discharge on
one of his nostrils it's mucus and
sometimes food will actually come
through it and it's bad so this thing is
just not going away this nasal discharge
not completely it's normally in the
mornings and it's always the right side
we did his teeth how long ago a couple
of months ago yes we identified a
fistulous track at his number eight
molar these fistulous tracks are
beneficial for draining infection but
they can become problematic if they
become little highways for bacteria to
travel up and down this could be what's
causing Henry's snotty nose but there
could be something more serious like an
abscessed tooth let's just take X-rays
of him and just see if we have you know
a root abscess or if it's just those
fistulous tracks if we don't have to
pull the tooth that's going to be our
first choice good I've only had them a
few months now but he's a good horse
come on Henry I want him to be
as healthy as I can make
let's rule out a bad tooth I'm going to
give him something to just calm him down
a little bit
I'm really hoping we could avoid pulling
this molar that's a really complicated
thing for a horse
he's easy horses spend their entire life
grinding the upper surface their upper
molars against their lower molars if we
don't have an upper molar there any
longer that lower molar the opposing
tooth on the lower side is going to
continue to grow so he's going to have a
peak in his mouth constantly that's
going to need chronic dental work and
horses don't like dental work any more
than people do the tooth we're looking
at is about right here okay okay let's
try this thing ready
oh
close to his face is he'll let you do it
ready I'm gonna miss the top part of the
jaw I'm going to hold it higher towards
the ceiling kind of higher easy I'm
losing them guys
[Music]
I gave him a sedative that should have
got him very relaxed this thing's heavy
he was still more in control than I
really wanted him to be okay
no no
this thing's heavy he was still more in
control than I really wanted him to be
there you go oh no doc Oli is trying to
get a look inside Henry's mouth but even
with sedation Henry's not having it you
gotta hold it higher because of his
alertness it took us several attempts to
get the views that I needed it's screwed
okay I'm gonna do it again it's just the
challenge of veterinary medicine
[Music]
air I think he's ready to go probably
didn't want to be around here any longer
probably not so I'm going to send Henry
home and take a look at these images and
that'll determine what we're going to do
next
good man Henry good man
okay catch you later thanks Doc
let's go inside and do this because I
want to get the orientation right okay
thank you
okay okay so Jill you can see at the
base of these teeth there's root prongs
if you will that are anchoring that
tooth into the bone of the jaw if we had
any kind of major disease going on in
there like a root tooth abscess we
wouldn't see those prongs because that
tooth is getting absorbed Away by the
infection but we're not seeing that not
the tooth's fault it's these fistulous
tracks I want to find a way to close up
those little tunnels Henry's develop
between the tooth and the sinuses I have
an idea for something that just might
work I've never done it with a horse but
there's a periodontal product that we
use in small animals to help attach
teeth to the mouth and it kind of fills
in that defect in the mouth I think the
plan is what we'll do is we'll get them
back in we're going to pack those
fistulas with this product and see if we
can stop it awesome sounds great all
right
[Music]
we have a drop off coming down this is a
small
laceration about three inches all right
Bill sorry to leave you that kind of a
mess no worries definitely put a belly
bandage on her because you've got
weepers from the skin gotcha hey Mandy
well hello there hi Mandy the German
Shepherd's mom is back to get doc
Ollie's verdict on what's happening with
her favorite girl first thing I did is I
went up the nose nothing everything
looked normal there you saw how snotty
and how like oh I picked her nose before
we got started yeah and I purposely
didn't you know because I wanted you to
see what it looked like so I wanted to
take an x-ray and I'll show you septums
intact everything looks good that fine
Lacy bone that we can see is a good
thing because nasal tumors and polyps
and things like that oftentimes this is
just solid gray so basically my
conclusion is is that more than likely
she's got a foreign body up in that nose
could be part of a grass on yeah yeah
yeah yeah she's an avid sniffer I was
really worried there could be like a
cancerous tumor or something she's nine
she's a shepherd and you know always
worried about something worse and that's
not it at all big really and it's going
to work itself out in the meantime we're
just going to symptomatically treat her
with the antibiotics okay and we'll just
keep doing that until one day she either
sneezes this thing out of her or the
body took care of it and cleaned it up
well I guess that's good news it's great
news Lisa's very attached to Mandy as it
should be I mean people should be
attached to their dogs and other than
her having to pick Mandy's nose every
day which is probably affecting Lisa's
quality of life it appears as though
Mandy's quality of life is just fine
thank you for doing a thorough
you got it we'll have it right up great
see and you're okay okay yeah there she
is
so good you're okay we were worried
about you she did great for us today
this is wonderful thank God everything
checked out let's go baby good job baby
girl
[Music]
doc Ollie is heading to Phoenix to
follow up with Mr Stubbs this alligator
lost his tail as a baby
and Doc Ollie's Consulting with the team
that's going to make him whole
all right
the Masterpiece huh if this high-tech
prosthetic tail Works Mr Stubbs is going
to move much better and have much less
pain as he ages oh wow already I like it
but right off the bat it's still the
weight of it
so we move the center of gravity forward
I like the fact that that there's no
fulcrum point I like the lacing system
as well it looks a lot like it's going
to be easier to apply to
grips that tail and keeps it from
sliding back that's a masterpiece this
type of work has a wide application in
veterinary medicine because there's a
lot of animals that lose Parts things
that animals definitely need
functionally as in Mr stubs so I am
excited to be part of it hey it's Mr
Stubbs
all right
[Music]
first fit
let's see oh that that's right so far
yep there you go that looks like that's
the thing
it's not moving it's on there so just as
we did with the first movement without
the tail
we're gonna record him walking again but
we can do a side-by-side comparison and
actually see the differences in movement
with and without the tail in a very high
resolution
so we are going to observe through this
3D animation does that tail improve his
gate all right stubs how about it
oh going on his own steps
you can see oh okay
technical difficulties not that we can't
fix this is why we're doing the trial
and error that's right we've got to keep
tweaking this every single time if it
won't seat any further down we may need
to remove some of the material from deep
inside there this scar piece right here
has to really sit right in that foam
there gotcha he's ready there we go yeah
that's right up where it needs to be
it's like a debutante at the ball
getting a corset on all right Mr Stubbs
let's see what you got
come on stubs
I want to take a couple steps for us
all right stubs down at it you want to
take a couple steps for us
there we go there we go nice come on
stubs you can do it good job and I'm
psyched look at that come on stubs
Dr Oley and the team have fitted Mr
Stubbs with a new prosthetic tale to
help him be a normal alligator
I'd keep coming
keep going good job you can really watch
that foot that foot's not sticking out
to the side you can really see it
staying in place
fast Improvement it was very dramatic to
see how Mr Stubbs could ambulate with
his tail more like a normal alligator
than when he didn't have his tail and
was really struggling to to move so I'm
really happy with the change in his gate
characteristics I'm going to call this a
biomedical Miracle we have some
obligation to be stewards of the animals
that find their way into our lives and
an animal that comes to live at a
sanctuary deserves the best treatment
that science can afford it
well thank you guys I see myself using
this technology and dozens of species
that I work with so I'm going to be
walking away as a better veterinarian
what I'm really excited about is to see
Mr Stubbs have that quality of life that
he desperately deserves
I think he's going to stay Mr Stubbs no
matter what even if he's got a big
beautiful prosthetic tail
have a great life
[Music]
good boy
wait man Animal Hospital this is Jody
how can I help you
I'm buddy okay all right Mr Sam
it seem like you've lost any weight
Henry the horse is back at White
Mountain for an experimental treatment
for his sign assailment all right Henry
be good about it
all right Dr Oli has a novel idea that
could heal Henry's fistulous tracks and
he needs Melissa the equine dentist to
help
can you swing him and vacuum into that
corner there Henry has seen Melissa
before and he's met Dr Oley and horses
have a good memory for people he's not
in love with doing anything like this
but he is a trusting Horse He trusts my
decision to bring him here he trusts
Melissa
the plan is we're going to flush out
those those fistulas got all kinds of
nasties coming out of there he's really
not packing any feed he's kind of trying
to get up into the gum a little bit
Henry has these tracks like tiny tunnels
between one of his teeth and his sinus
cavity and that acts as a breeding
ground for infection the first step is
to clean out the tracks so we can get
them plugged we're going to apply a
osteogenic putty up there which is a big
word for helps to create bone growth and
product that we are going to attempt to
clog these fistulas with is used pretty
extensively in small animal Dentistry
I've never used it in a horse
but in theory it should work it feels
great for me to be able to do Innovative
things using this compound may prove to
be a very effective technique and this
is a way that we can actually give Henry
back a dry nose and a comfortable mouth
I'm kind of excited to see if this is
going to work are you I am very I'm glad
his tooth is viable this is the first
time for me to be able to do something
to keep the tooth because you really
want to try to keep the tooth if you can
okay let's do this thing let's apply the
putty in there I made you little
sections of it oh and then fish it in
there and just go in digitally with it
we'll get that in as far as we can okay
for me to put these mitts inside a
horse's mouth halfway back the molar I
could do it by field she can do it by
sight I want this to work well and with
her small hand she's able to get in
there and get the job done easy
you're all right you're all right
that one's a little bit deeper don't get
too aggressive it is super thick yeah it
is thick come on come on Henry we're
almost done buddy to keep it underneath
this tooth
Henry
do you want to try to get him a little
less combative let me go grab something
I'll be right back this is Henry's third
dental procedure in about two months I
think Henry's just tired of having his
mouth messed with
I touched him up with a little cocktail
Better Living Through Chemistry yes I
like it
here we go Henry
that's how we like you that's the way we
do it
for guy
[Music]
let's get it up in there the best you
can
[Music]
advise right improvise adapt and
overcome
that words to live by what Dr Oli does
is he brainstorms and figures out a way
to fix it you know this is cool I've
never done this before okay
done that's it
good job
we had to think uh outside of the box a
little bit you have to figure out a way
to solve the problem you got to do it
well and you got to do it to the benefit
of the animal to have all that happen is
an amazing feeling professionally for me
and this is one day when it did post-op
stuff is all the water he wants but no
food until the day after tomorrow
morning if he just keeps his tongue off
of it for a day and a half and he
doesn't have a chance to disrupt the
Integrity of that putty it should
already start doing its thing Dr Oley
came up with a plan and today we
implemented the plan I like the fact
that doc can think outside the box and
and do something that is necessary to
fix a horse that that other people
couldn't do thanks Doc all right we got
her done
good boy
[Music]